[Music]
how is cristian cásseres greeting you with
his informative roll of news now in
Spanish the
expiration date of the moratorium on evictions is approaching
this regulation was intended to
keep people inside their homes
during the pandemic in county court
a multitude of evictions are expected to happen
in July but if you are still facing
financial problems and you receive an
eviction order it is recommended to fill out a
form through the court they advise
you to petition so you can evaluate your
case this gets the county to review it
and  an employee walks you through the steps to
get help and other resources
and if you still need to get your
coronavirus shot there are plenty of clinics
around the valley for this
weekend i heard this hustlers to
administer doses
from 4-7pm this  friday saturday
you can attend the community center
for country or mount insights park or
you can receive your vaccine through a
window in the como  location of your car
at fire station 38 for a
complete list visit news now dotcom
diagonal en español tus ojos por las
vegas is approaching its grand
opening day the nevada gaming board
approved the license for the
property everything will be ready  for its grand
opening Thursday June 24th and we have
a small drop in temperatures
after several days of high winds
we will have temperatures in the high
70s temperatures will climb back
into the high eighties and nineties by
next week tremendous relief for
many  Since these temperatures are
unusual for this time of year, I'm
Cristian Cásseres with your new
News Now program in Spanish. Good
day
[Music]